everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today I wanted to go over a
quick trap but one that I enjoy it's a
trap in the old benoni defense so if
you're not familiar with the old bodoni
starts out with pawn to d4 and then pawn
to c5 Black's going to temporarily give
up material in exchange for white giving
up one of his strongest pawns obviously
the pawn on e5 and the D file are the
most important they control the center
of the board so blacks going to
temporarily I say temporarily because it
is going to be extremely difficult for
white to hold on to the material if he
does take that but in this tutorial
we're going to be going over if white
does take on c5 so from here blacks
going to play pawn to e6 he's allowing
his dark square Bishop to get involved
into the game obviously black would like
his bishop to come to c5 he's there then
attacking the square here on f2 which is
we talked about in our other videos is
the weakest square for white early on
into the game so best-case scenario the
bishops going to take back this material
on c5 now my opinion the best route for
white for here is actually to give back
the material so many people anytime
they're up in material they feel like
they have to hold on to that material
any time you can still stay with the
lead in advantage as far as development
or an attack give up material you don't
have to hold on to it but so many people
do feel the need to hold on to it so in
this situation white really has two
different ideas as far as holding on to
it he can play Bishop to e3 one option
and then pawn to b4 which is actually
where our trap is going to be coming
from today first one I do want to go
over is Bishop to e3 just you can see if
you actually are playing this game from
here black can just play Knight to c6
again simple development move we do have
this semi open file for our Rick to come
on the C file later on to the game if we
need to after our Knight comes to c6 our
other Knights going to be coming to f6
and then is going to be coming to g4 as
well trying to get this Bishop off here
on a u3 again it's going to be very
difficult for white to hold on to this
pawn on c5 but this bishop here on e3 is
really hampering the development of the
key
side from white which is not worldwide
once obviously white later on would like
to push his 'if pawn forward into the
game he would then like to get his light
square bishop involved into the game
trying to attack this diagonal right
here he would also like to get his
knight involved into the game and then
castle on the King side if he so pleases
but a lot of times and said the bishop
move coming to e3 hindering the
development from white players will
always play pawn to b4 i play the king's
games a lot anytime that you know
they're trying to pull on to this pawn
on f4 a lot of times you'll see you know
the knight or excuse me the pawn coming
to g5 same with the old Bodoni defense
on the queenside players would like to
play pawn to b4 trying to hold on to
this pawn on c5 then from here black
dali has to do is play pawn to a5 and I
feel like from here blacks actually
already equalized so the first thing you
want to do from black anytime you're
playing is you want to equalize white
obviously has a distinct advantage going
first
he does have that lead in development
he's usually the one attacking early on
so anytime black can equalize in a game
or become you know get closer and closer
to equalizing especially in this case
we're only three moves into the game
it's going to be very very good for
black so just keep that in mind whenever
you're playing first thing you want to
do from black is you want to equalize
now from here white can always take if
you want to he could take on a5 you know
black can capture on c5 as we talked
about very great square for us you know
getting our dark square Bishop involved
into the game controlling the center of
the board obviously why it's also going
to lose this pawn on a5 we have both the
Queen here on d8 and we also have the
rook here on a both attacking it not
only is black now equal and material
after he takes this pawn on a5 but he's
also now leading in a development
standpoint trying to control the center
of the board here so white doesn't have
a whole lot going for him now do note
that if white does try to hold on to
this pawn on a5 which you really
shouldn't do but you know a lot of times
people again as we talked about always
trying to hold on immaterial if he does
play let's say Bishop to d2 obviously
now we're not going to take with our
queen or our rook here
on the eighth-ranked but now black and
just bring his Queen to f6 black is now
threatening to bring his queen and
checkmate here so whites now going to be
losing this rook here on a1 again he
could always if he wanted to you know
try to salvage the the rook here on a1
but then again he's going to start
losing a lot more material he could
bring his Queen here to f2 he could
bring his bishop here to f2 so it's
obviously either way why it's still
going to lose a material so as far as
White's concerned he should pretty much
just you know lose this pawn right here
I mean he could always develop with
Knight to f3 again trying to stop this
but again from here Queens just going to
come to a1 and gobble up this this rook
here on a1 so you know again as we
talked about before blacks going to
equalize especially in material once he
takes this pawn here on a5 but if white
does try anything you know with this
Bishop to d2 you do have other options
but a lot of times white might actually
play a different move instead of taking
on a5 obviously as we talked about that
would be a mistake but you may make the
mistake and play pawn to c3 this is
actually a mistake because we can take
right back with pawn taking on b4 now I
do just want to preface this so many
people always watch the trap videos and
tell me that someone made a mistake and
no one would ever play like that now I
do understand that you know you may be
the greatest chess player that's ever
played and you've never played someone
that made a mistake but I also get a lot
of people saying hey Kevin you know my
opponents are making mistakes but I
don't know how to capitalize on those
mistakes so again this is a trap video
so someone is going to make a mistake if
you don't enjoy that then you can always
watch a different video but in this
situation we're going to be going of our
trap so someone did make a mistake in
this case the first mistake is just pawn
to c3 obviously it doesn't do a whole
lot white really is trying to hold on to
this pawn on b4 which is the defender of
the pawn on c5 but it just kind of
starts to crumble if white does take on
b4 then black can just play
Queen to f6 and he's going to win
material and obviously white right now
is going to lose his rook on a1 unless
he does something do really only option
that he does have here as if his knight
comes to c3 he's just going to have to
sacrifice that knight on c3 and after
the bishop comes here to d2 then the
Queen can come back to a3 obviously
black is not only up in material now but
he does have a lot more going form
obviously he's leading in development
it's going to be a lot easier for him to
get his dark square Bishop involved into
the game castle on the King side White
has done nothing on his King side is all
none of his minor pieces major pieces
have developed not even his King pawn
has developed so it's going to be very
very hard for white to really not only
do anything in the game but even get his
pieces developed into the game obviously
black still does have the semi open file
for his rook here on a8 he's going to be
attacking a lot to the game obviously
next move he can bring his knight to c6
really tried to control the center of
the board he can always bring his knight
to f6 you know trying to control this
efore square if white tries to push
forward so a lot of things going for
black obviously this is going to be a
very very difficult game for white to
play so again the reason I like this
trap is because the open Oni is actually
very very powerful for black it's very
easy to equalize there's a lot of great
opportunities to attack and even if
white does not you know make the mistake
and he doesn't you know defend with his
pawn with you know b4 and even after the
pawn comes to a5 he doesn't play c3 and
he doesn't fall for the trap blacks
still going to have a very very good
game so that's one of the reason why is
like this even if you watch the video
and say Kevin no one would ever do that
that's completely fine you can
completely ignore the trap itself this
is still going to be a great defense if
you do play this and you see someone
fall for the trap which I have a few
times it's always fun to lay a trap on
someone so again just pawn takes on on
b4 and after they take on b4 you're just
going to bring your Queen to f6 so
hopefully you guys enjoyed another trap
video I've got a few more coming out in
the near future feel free to leave
comments and I'll see you guys in the
next video
thanks for watch